This function that describes how the coefficient of friction depends on the wheel slip
is a vital part of the simulation.
The tricky thing about is that it stems from experiments. It contains empirical data.
We do not have any nice equation for that curve--that is not until now.
One way to deliver such empirical data in this simulation would be
to use a lookup table such as this one.
If we input a wheel slip of zero, we output a coefficient of friction that's zero as well.
If we input a wheel slip of 0.1, we output a coefficient of friction that's 0.9 and so on.
This would constitute a lookup table.
The tricky thing is what would you do for a wheel slip of say 0.01234.
What do you do about values of s that are not contained in this column?
We have to somehow interpolate these values, which gets complex
and it's not easy to do in a smooth fashion.
A simple approach is to use a phenomenological equation to guess how one could
possibly describe this in mathematics without worrying about the reasons for
why it looks the way it looks.
We just collect some mathematical functions that produce the right shape.
If you look at the shape of this function, you may come up with the following idea--
for reasonably large values of s, this function almost is a line so why not use that line
as one component in our equation.
Close to zero it looks as though we are subtracting
a quickly decaying function such as e^(-20s).
Your job is now to make this work.
Pick the right value for the constant a and then implement this function in Python.